there's five stages that happen for any
kind of behavioral change one is
uninformed optimism right
uh which is where the grass is greener
and you're like that looks exciting so
someone jumps into a new niche and
they're like this is awesome dentists
make money i'm gonna go after dentists
then they go to stage two which is
informed pessimism they now know that
this is not nearly as cool as they
thought it was these guys have horrible
front desks they're not business acumen
people they're painting they have to
make decisions they're over analyzing
cool stage three is depression or
determination this is where like
champions are made where people fall off
which is where most people fall off and
so there's two paths from here path
number one which is what ninety percent
of people do is they jump back to stage
one in a different niche and they start
over again and they say you know what
it's going to be chiropractors
chiropractors are the guys
it's totally different and they just
continue this this rabbit hole and and
the false belief they have is
i'm gonna do all three and see which one
works
when in reality is you need to pick one
and make it work because all three can
work but none of them can work together